cuál es el volumen de la siguiente
figura
bueno vemos que el volumen es el ancho
por la profundidad por la altura
el volumen va a ser volumen va a ser
igual a nos dicen que este lado es x + 4
x 4
por la profundidad que es x + 1 x 1 por
la altura que es x 6
qué pueden hacer esta operación en su
mente pero vamos a escribir la x + 4 x 4
x x + 1
x 1 multiplicación esto por uno es
4 más x
x x 4 es 4x
x x x es x para
ok sumamos
4 x 4 x es igual a 5 x mas x cuadrado
ahora todo esto lo vamos a multiplicar
por x 6 esto lo multiplicamos por x 6
y espero que me quepan vamos a ver
6 x 4 24
6 x 5 x va a ser igual a 30 x 6 x x al
cuadrado va a ser igual a 6 x cuadrado
debajo x por todo esto x por 44 x
5x x x es igual a 5x cuadrada 5x
cuadrada y voy a invadir un poco de este
lado x x x cuadrada es x al cubo
si se alcanza a ver si se alcanza a ver
ok ahora vamos a sumar estos dos esto
aquí no tenemos nada abajo nos queda 24
30 x + 4 x va a ser igual a 34 x
6x cuadrada + 5x cuadrada es igual a 11
x cuadrada
y ya que tenemos son un término con x
cúbica va a ser igual a x al cubo
esta es mi respuesta y vemos de las
opciones no todas comienzan con esto más
11 x cuadrada ok pueden ser estas 2 más
34 x aquí esta es mi opción b
+ 24 es está muy bien ahora continuamos
con el siguiente problema el número 14 8
a kubica más c kubica es igual a nos dan
estas opciones y esto no es tan trivial
de resolver
pensemos en ello para poder tener un
número positivo en 8 a kubica y veamos
la opción a cumple con esta parte 2a por
2 x 2 a va a ser 8 a kubica pero es
interesante que me da la sensación de
querer quitar esta opción de entrada
descartarla inmediatamente esta opción
la a es lo mismo que si yo escribo 2 a
más al cubo y cada vez que lo multiplicó
se van a agregar más términos por
ejemplo el cuadrado de 2 a c
más c x 2 el cuadrado 2
se va a ser igual a 2 a por 2 a 4 a
cuadrado 2 a porsche más 2 ac
por dos más dos hace también más se
cuadrada aquí tengo estos términos
adicionales que luego no lo puedo
simplificar como 4a cuadrada más 4 hace
más cuadrada pero aquí ya tiene un
término que mi pregunta original no
tiene amigos john original no tiene así
que está y se viene en hacer caso a mis
instintos esta se quita veamos la opción
b me gusta de analizar los términos con
a 11 para ver si podemos cancelar algo
de la opción b 2 por 4 a cuadrada si me
va a dar 8 a kubica pero este menos se
por el pse cuadrado me va a dar menos sé
kubica ésta no me sirve porque tengo
aquí más sé kubica está también se va
esta segunda opción también tengo una
menos igual esta no me va a servir por
lo tanto va a ser la opción de vamos a
verificar lo vamos a hacer la
multiplicación 4a cuadrada menos 2 hace
más se cuadrada eso lo vamos a
multiplicar por dos o más hacemos la
multiplicación
c porsche cuadradas e kubica
por menos dos hace no hacer menos dos
hace cuadrada
c x 4 cuadrada 4 cuadrada c
ahora aquí abajo 2 a porsche al cuadrado
2 a c cuadrada es positivo
- 12 x 2 va a ser igual a menos 4 a
cuadradas y 4 a cuadrada por 2 a va a
ser igual a 8 a kubica
ok hacemos la suma de estos 2
más por cierto aquí tengo una cúbica 2
hace cuadrada menos 12 cuadradas se van
esto va a ser un 0 4 a cuadradas menos 4
a cuadradas e también se va esto es un 0
y me queda 8 a kubica que es lo que me
están preguntando me están especificando
al inicio así que en efecto mi respuesta
correcta es la opción d
ok pasamos al siguiente problema
voy a centrar un poco mejor para que se
noten todo ok
el área total de un rectángulo es de 4 x
a la cuarta menos 9 y cuadrada qué
factores representan el largo y el ancho
el área del rectángulo sabemos que el
área de un rectángulo es lado x
ancho o largo por ancho y me están
diciendo que ese es el área esto va a
ser igual a 4 x a la cuarta menos 9 y
cuadrado
hasta cierto punto tenemos que
factorizar esto en múltiples expresiones
y lo primero que deben buscar al
factorizar cualquier tipo de expresión
es ver si coincide con la estructura a
cuadrada
- de cuadrado de ser así y parece que
ésta coincide tenemos esto que podría
ser nuestra cuadrada y es a nuestra vez
cuadrada
y cuadrada es igual a 4x a la cuarta
sería igual a 2 x cuadrado
2x cuadradas sive cuadrada fuera igual a
al cuadrado me ve sería igual a 3 x
y esto es igual a cuadrada menos b
cuadrados está en el formato que
queremos
esto sería factor izando lo nos queda a
menos b por amarre o viceversa a es 2x
cuadrada x cuadrada
más bien de estrés
2x cuadradas
-3 y esta es mi opción y veamos el
último problema de este vídeo que es
nuestro problema número 16 que producto
de factores es equivalente a x + 1 al
cuadrado menos y cuadrado lo primero que
vamos a hacer es simplificar muy que
creen no tenemos que simplificar esto ya
está en la forma o el patrón a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada esto es a y esto sería
b
cuadrada es igual
al cuadrado y ve cuadrada iguala y
cuadrada así que a en este caso a es x 1
es sí
y se factores como a más ve o sea x más
uno más
x uno más por menos b x más uno menos
y revisamos nuestras opciones y es la
opción de esta de acá
esto fue más fácil de lo que pensaba nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo